(upbeat chiptune)
- Strong Museum in Rochester, New York,
is also know as the
National Museum of Play.
More than half million objects are here.
My name is Chris Bench, I'm vice president
for collections of the
museum and its chief curator.
Our collections are divided by category
and here are some of the people
who are responsible for that:
Nicolas Ricketts is
Curator of Board Games.
- In our collection, we have
around 10,000 board games
and it parallels, essentially,
American History since the Revolution.
When you think in terms of games,
they all tend to represent the areas
in which they were created.
It’s a different way of
getting into the mindset
of people who lived a hundred years ago.
- There's Michelle Parnett
Dwyer, Curator of Dolls.
- In this collection, we
have more than 15,000 dolls
and it spans from the 18th
century to present day.
Dolls are special because
of the way that we connect
with them, we project ourselves,
our hobbies, our interests,
our values towards others.
When we look at the history of dolls
and how we've played with them,
it shows that we connect
to people from the past
in ways that we might not have expected.
- Martin Reinhardt, head of pinball
and arcade game collections.
- We've over 250 arcade machines
and over 100 pinball
machines in the collection.
Pinball is real, you can
feel the way the game plays,
you can feel the way the
game moves as you're playing.
It's just in my nature to
keep these machines going.
They were made the last five years
in a commercial environment and the fact
that we have games that are 30, 40,
50, 60 years old is amazing to me.
- So I'm Curator responsible
for General Toys,
things like action figures and yo-yos.
This collection has more
than 70,000 objects.
Toys always reflect what's going on
in the world around them, when it's
economic boom times,
construction toys are big.
When US is at war, we see all
sorts of military and war toys.
The toy collection is a wonderful example
of how times have changed and
people have changed over the years.
Play is really important,
it's an integral part
to who we are as human beings,
only by understanding
how play has stayed the same
and more importantly,
changed over the years,
can we understand how
we've developed as people
and how we've played over the centuries.
(upbeat music)